camiseta a rayas arneses alrededor del
cuerpo los marinos del buque escuela
mexicano Cuauhtémoc que por estos días
participa de la exposición de los
veleros más bellos del mundo en el
puerto de ruán en Francia se preparan
para el momento más importante del día
Gerardo es parte de la tripulación y con
más experiencia entrega Sus consejos a
los nuevos marinos que en pocos minutos
suben por los mástiles para hacer una
inspección del estado de las velas en
una arriesgada maniobra que cautiva a
quienes observan más que nada que tengan
la seguridad y la confianza de lo que
hacen para que pues el miedo como todo
es un poco de alerta entre los que
realizan esta Audaz tarea está Carolina
desde 1998 las mujeres entraron a La
Marina en México y en el Cuauhtémoc son
36 un poco más del 10% de la tripulación
sus padres sorprendidos con su elección
la acompañan cada vez que zarpa y recala
en México con mucho esfuerzo han venido
a Francia la primera vez en el
extranjero es algo muy bonito para
nosotros como Paz nos sentimos muy
orgullosos de nuestra hija
14.000 personas por día han subido el
buque en Francia entre la acogida y las
demandas de selfie el evento es una
prueba más a la paciencia necesaria en
la formación de los marinos
es la visita obligada para ver barcos de
todos los países y este Es
verdaderamente el más bonito
vine a visitar este barco es
impresionante es uno de los más grandes
y la bandera mexicana atrae dan ganas de
venir a verlo
este Crucero del Cuauhtémoc recién
comienza tras la Habana Boston y ruán el
navío tiene aún cinco meses de travesía
por el Mediterráneo Inglaterra y el
Atlántico antes de volver a su base en
Acapulco El próximo cuatro de diciembre